[Applause]
hahaha
happy Monday everybody ah wow so while
Hunter Biden abuses the Arts Alvin Bragg
sniffs his own farts
Hunter the most successful crackhead the
world has ever seen is returning to New
York this week to exhibit his awful
abstract artwork at a Soho art gallery I
haven't seen a mess like this since I
that time I took a laxative with four
bags of Skittles
it was for pride month I was trying to
poop a rainbow
Hunter was spotted at the gallery over
the weekend even as a congressional
committee is trying to find out who the
hell is paying between 75 and 500 Grand
each for his crappy paintings
although that looks pretty good I have
to say
maybe he does have talent meanwhile in
Arkansas's judge ordered Hunter's
Financial records to be shielded from
the public as he tries to lower his
child support payments to London Roberts
she's the dancer he knocked up while he
was banging his brother's widow and
sleeping with the brothers widow's
sister-in-law or something
I'd say do the math but we have two
women on the panel
[Applause]
and what kind of poverty can Hunter be
claiming as a reason to lower these
payments what he doesn't have enough
cash to buy diapers for his kid and his
dad
he's also trying to keep his
illegitimate daughter Navy Joan from
taking the Biden name which you gotta
ask how will she ever make a living if
she can't trade on that name but maybe
when she turns five she'll be qualified
to join an oil company's board of
directors
of course this is happening as Donald
Trump is under indictment in Manhattan a
precedent that can't mean good news for
the current president's pampered progeny
I mean if we're going to start
Prosecuting Rich powerful men for paying
off sex workers
let's not forget Congress who used to
pay off sexual harassment suits through
taxpayer-funded accounts they had a
slush fund for sleaze and remember that
Bill Clinton paid 850 Grand to settle
the Paula Jones suit that's classic Bill
though thousands to settle a suit and
not a dime to dry clean a dress
[Applause]
a stain on his presidency
question where was Chelsea Clinton when
Epstein was murdered
okay
yeah you can't answer it can you I rest
my case but really buying Story made
Daniel's silence might not have been
Trump's best idea ever especially since
it didn't work it just goes to show you
even 130 Grand can't convince a woman to
stop talking
what's this would say point is we know
this this is political because it's
always political and it might be
harmless were it not for the opportunity
costs meaning what do you miss when
everyone's on a political Witch Hunt
well Islamic terrorists for one while we
were impeaching Clinton what were they
up to they were making plans for 72
virgins just like Clinton
but they had already bombed the World
Trade Center in 93 and yet years later
we still took our eyes off the ball and
like Monica Lewinsky put them squarely
on bills
[Laughter]
[Music]
first impeachment happened while covid
erupted out of China we lost two months
in that battle because the media chose
to focus on the orange monster instead
of the Red Menace makes you wonder how
many lives could have been saved if the
median politicians had done the right
and Urgent thing first but they didn't
they were too busy kissing Andrew
Cuomo's ass and being kissed back
and now a huge story broke last week AI
researchers pleaded with us to shut down
the tech for at least six months that's
roughly the time it takes to recover
from a hair transplant
making a comparison
a letter signed by Elon Musk in apple
's dressed that a superhumanly smart AI
that gets beyond our control spells
death for all of us I only hope I'll be
spared as a sex slave
looking forward to it I volunteered
actually
to my toaster but
that was a day before the indictment
news which is now a forever ago you
notice what all three have in common
Terror covid AI they are deadly things
that can get away from us if we aren't
watching that's how I lost my pet python
choki
in this studio an hour ago
and so another opportunity to prevent
suffering is squandered on the altar of
political Vengeance it's a hunting party
and you're among the prey you ever see
this movie they're not human beings
every year a bunch of Elites kidnap
normal folks like us where'd they get
you from fly only Mississippi Orlando
and Hunt us for sport
hurry hurry hurry up
so it's true we're being hunted
that's from three years ago it's insane
but damn if it didn't predict the hunt
since then parents were called domestic
terrorists January 6 demonstrators
jailed in Mass kids are now medical
subjects for delusional activists the
IRS hires 80 000 agents and stalks a
reporter while he's speaking truth to
power BLM rioters get payouts instead of
prison and when kids got killed at a
school the White House said we must
protect the trans it certainly feels
like we are the problem from their
perspective not fence at all or the
homeless or the Border nope it's us at
least until the world ends due to
climate change and AOC says we have only
12 months left
tonight's guess
she didn't write the old man in the sea
but you can always tell when something's
fishy editor-in-chief of the Federalist
Molly Hemingway
and like a fat guy at a buffet he
Embraces all sides co-host of the five
Harold Ford Jr
this man needs no introduction because
he's a last minute replacement for
Charlie hurt
hahaha
comedian Joe Mackey
and clubs call her a comedian to watch
because she keeps stealing silverware
Fox News contributor captive
Joe Mackey always a pleasure to see you
even if it's on short notice and I
didn't want you thanks for having me
Greg yes
what is your take um you can you got a
it's a it's a potpourri if you the hunt
Hunter we've we've learned a lot this
week Greg Justice isn't blind in fact
she has purple hair and a nose ring
uh it just seems like uh it's like we're
driving with Tiger Woods everything ends
up upside down
but I'll say this I don't like all the
comparisons we was saying uh Hey if you
arrest Trump we're going to arrest you
know Hunter Biden or Joe Biden or
Hillary Clinton because they were
actually guilty of real things
when they say no one is above the law
I'm like that's true I think no one is
above the law but when it's uh hush
money beyond the statute of limitations
I'm not that worried about it if I try
to keep things positive Greg yeah like
Trump's day today was he woke up and got
on his own 757 and came to New York and
tomorrow he gets arrested and then he's
going to go back to his luxury building
foreign
that's better than the best day I've
ever had
you know Molly I was watching the
coverage and I'll include our Network on
it but we everybody has all the cameras
trained on the car and I just had
visions of OJ and Al cowlings Junior
I don't know why I pointed at you and
said Junior I'd say hey you both are
Juniors but anyway
we need Trump I feel like it's like
something that like all of a sudden it
was like we just quit doing Oxycontin
and now we started it up again and it
feels great it is absolutely
I mean it is amazing to watch how much
the media have to focus on him I mean
this is a really legitimate big story
this is yeah big news it's not a good
day for the country that we're going
through this but they you can tell how
excited everybody is yeah cover it and
you know I'm I'm hoping it's not like
too exciting tomorrow though yeah what
do you think is going to happen what do
you think his speech is going to be like
I don't know about that but I was kind
of like thinking it would be cool to see
what his mug shot is like like I hope he
does a really big grin you know a thumbs
up something that
he is going to turn that into like the
most I got like the biggest selling
t-shirt in the history of t-shirts I'm
buying it yeah exactly it'll be better
than the I'm with stupid one
he'll put it on a mug yeah he'll put it
on a mug that's a great idea I didn't
think of that Joe's got is full of ideas
not bad for a substitute anyway
Harold it's good to see you always a
pleasure to have you on the show good to
be back around the living room here yes
it is it is it is you we were talking
about this on the five and we're it's
such a strange and surreal experience
and I like what you said there you said
you reminded everybody that he's
innocent which is something Nancy Pelosi
forgot about
I think anybody that forgets that um
does a disservice to the to the judicial
system I I get concerned when I hear
either side talk that way we have one
system of justice we are a nation built
in a rule of laws there are two
predicates to our system one is everyone
is presumed innocent and so proven
unless they're they're found guilty and
two facts and evidence always reign in a
courtroom we have checks and balances in
the judicial system meaning if you get
you don't like the outcome in the lower
court you can appeal and you can go all
the way to the Supreme Court so you have
two ways to check it I would caution
Democrats show restraint uh this is not
a time I agree with Molly in this regard
this is not a good day for the country
it's not a good day for the president
either but it's not a good day for the
country and my only hope is if there's
not enough there to convict I hope a
court uh dismisses or decides this case
before it goes to trial and if there is
enough if there are new charges I hope
we all can be open-minded enough to
understand if the country's bigger than
one person uh and let the trial go
forward if indeed his lawyers want that
to happen what do you think of Hunter's
art
well I've never seen it I've only seen
what little you've shown here and I can
only react the way you thought it was
better than what you were is that python
underneath me
no but thank you
we should go back and talk about Hunter
I thought I'm gonna be you know I'm not
going to be on for the rest of the week
and people are going to think it's
because of that joke
who was the victim here cat are there
any dims by the way yeah well I do have
to come here tomorrow and you know the
traffic is going to be like it's great
I've noticed the question I was gonna
ask ask you he's gonna tie up all tracks
I've already gone through the
Rockefeller Christmas okay it's finally
now it's springtime now we got Trump
traffic
um no but he like it's not like he hates
being on TV it's like he hates attention
and like you were saying I mean he
wasn't really in the news that much
anymore yeah and now it's all Trump all
the time once again and I really don't
see I mean again I haven't seen it but I
don't see if it's just what we're all
we've all been talking about how he gets
convicted on this yeah so that's why
when everyone's saying okay like no
one's Above the Law no one's above law
because actually when it comes to the
way they're using this law and trying to
do this he is the only one who's ever
been gone through or has ever had it
used that way so I don't know I I don't
he's never actually gonna like go to
prison for this unless there's something
that I don't know that would be such an
amazing sitcom to go to jail with Secret
Service agents it'd be kind of like
Hogan's Heroes right it would be Hogan's
Heroes your friends without like you
have police on your side yeah you have
like a little microphone in the teacup
no wait no teapot you have a phone in
the teapot
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else